die verpflichtenden grenzverfahren kann
man heute schon überall machen die
Griechen machen sie Italien könnte sie
machen warum macht Italien für die die
über das Meer kommen keine
verpflichtenden grenzverfahren in diesem
Jahr sind 50.000 Menschen in Boten aus
Westafrika in Italien
angekommen in diese Länder gibt es keine
Rückführungen Italien macht keine
Rückführungen nach ginea nicht nach
elfenmeinküste nicht und übrigens
Frankreich im ganzen letzten Jahr hat
Italien 200 Rückführungen in Länder
subsahara Afrika 200 200 200 da W
Ägypten ist auch schon schönes ypten im
letzten Jahr
21300 Menschen aus Ägypten nach Italien
im Boot Rückführungen nach Italien ich
habe jetzt Eurostat sagt mir 300 oder
150 die IT sagen 300 also nichts es
kommen 21 000 Rückführungen 150 200 also
quasi
[Musik]
nichts